poor Joe out with their tools good
afternoon everybody like to welcome you
to today's Commission press briefing
today is Thursday the 7th of August 2014
they begin by a brief statement from us
the European Union regrets the
announcement by the Russian Federation
of measures which will target imports of
food and agricultural products the
announcement is clearly politically
motivated the Commission would assess
the measures in question as soon as we
have more information as to the full
content and extent we underline that the
European Union's restrictive measures
are directly linked with the illegal
annexation of Crimea and the separation
of Ukraine the European Union remains
committed to the escalating station in
Ukraine all to join in this effort
following a full assessment by the
Commission on the Russian Federation's
measures we reserve the right to take
action that's a reaction from the EU
from the European Commission similar to
the announcements made yesterday and
this morning by the Russian Federation
even taking measures on imports of food
and agricultural products from the
European Union we haven't yet received
all of the details with regard to the
measures in question so that's all I can
say for now before we move to questions
from you let me make a brief statement
about tomorrow tomorrow in the EAS
building at half past 10:00 there be a
brief off-the-record technical briefing
on the Gaza situation if you want to
know more about that get in touch with
Sebastia and the EAS today now having
said that the floor is yours